moving on
our main story tonight concerns asian
americans a group that currently makes
up around seven percent of the us
population and is actually the fastest
growing racial group and yet despite
that
asian americans can sometimes be oddly
overlooked a recent survey asked
respondents to simply name a well-known
asian american
and the results were not good forty-two
percent of people said that
they don't know one the next most
popular answers were
jackie chan who's from hong kong and
bruce lee
who died in 1973. oh come
on no disrespect to jackie chan and
bruce lee there but that is embarrassing
even before you consider the poll was
conducted while kamala harris
who's asian american was vice president
how do you up a question that easy
it'd be like asking americans to name a
well-known joe and getting back
what's joe john krasinski and joe
millionaire
it is pretty clear many in this country
don't seem to know much about the
histories or experiences
of asian americans and to the extent
that experience has been discussed in
recent years it's often been in a tragic
context such as killings or mass
shootings or racism around the
coronavirus triggering verbal and
physical attacks in the street
as well as the kind of idiocy that
forced local news to have to produce
pieces like
no you can't get coronavirus by eating
chinese food
because of course you can't
you're right is likely to get
coronavirus from eating chinese food
as you want to get chickenpox from
eating kfc that's not going to happen
and it's alarming anyone thought it
might and all of this
has highlighted the need for us to have
a long overdue better informed
conversation
about the way this country regards asian
americans
and before we start i fully recognize
the history of white people on tv
generalizing confidently about this
subject isn't great
sometimes making statements that are
offensive even when they think they're
being complementary like this idea that
has come up
constantly they've worked their way past
column a's and column b's
past no starch please to become our
nation's model minority
listen to the numbers median family
income higher for asians than for whites
once again super achieving asian
american students are becoming a
phenomenon
they are over achievers driven to excel
by tradition
the academic achievement of asian
american students are so notable that in
some colleges
students warn each other that if they
end up in a class with a lot of oriental
faces
get out the grading curve they say will
go out of sight
wow that is jarring to here especially
when delivered with such a weird
combination of amused self-satisfaction
and totally inappropriate sourcing
i was eavesdropping on some teens last
week and i heard one of them say
never share a cab with a black person
just thought i'd pass that along this
has been for some reason the news
but that idea that asian americans are a
model minority
has been as persistent as it is
problematic so tonight
we thought we'd try and unpack both
parts of this sentence and let's start
with the first half asian americans
we're actually going to spend
most of our time on this term because
it's having to do a lot of work
it encompasses a vast group who can
trace their heritage back to more than
20 countries
covering a huge amount of the world's
land mass from mongolia
to indonesia to pakistan to japan and
even some who fall under the term asian
american or the broader
aapi which includes pacific islanders
feel that it may not fit them or
that the broadness of the category means
their experiences get erased
people associate asian with east asian
filipinos aren't
so much dismissed they're just
overlooked just because they're not as
popular within at least the american
culture sometimes i will identify
as asian but then other indian people
don't identify as asian why are you
considered asian you're in the pacific
islander wouldn't you be considered more
hawaiian and i'm like
not really yeah the term asian american
applies to a ridiculously
large and diverse group of people and
there is clearly
not going to be enough time to discuss
everyone who supposedly fits under that
umbrella in this piece even though i do
intend
to talk very fast so apologies in
advance to all 127
maldivian americans i promise i will
make it up to my one maldivian american
fan in the future i am serious kareem
stay with me trust me on this you will
be seen
but the fact the term asian american is
so incredibly broad
isn't an accident it was kind of the
point from the start because it was
first coined
in the late 1960s by asian american
student activists in california
who went on strike alongside black
hispanic and native american students to
demand
an ethnic studies curriculum in those
days the term asian american didn't
exist
we were all orientals
1968 that was the first time that i
heard the term
asian americans asian american
encompasses everybody i said
wow that's something people are finally
starting to realize that
we wear our race on our face it's true
under a system of white supremacy we do
tend to wear our race on our face
my face for example is currently wearing
down market vintage
colonial casual i'd change it into
something a little less imperial if i
could but i can't so instead
i wear these glasses for those activists
the term asian american
was an attempt to unite a massively
diffuse community in solidarity thus
increasing their power and crucially
forcing their universities to devote
resources to making sure the histories
of
all their communities were actually
taught it was a political term
a radical redefinition at the time but
it's since become a common shorthand
that can unfortunately end up being used
in a way that is
far too reductive and superficial to the
point where an
old government psa felt the need to make
a pretty obvious statement
people always ask me how i like america
my great grandfather was born here like
most americans
we've been american for a long time
some of us follow asian traditions my
family is apple pie american
mini bikes football rocket tie
all asian americans are no more alike
than any other kind of americans
we don't all look alike do we
well do we the government money
paid for that
even this kid has a smirk that says
white people
although i will admit the writer of that
psa defining apple pie american as
mini bikes football rock guitar is
magnificent
it should be the oath of citizenship you
put your hand over your heart say
mini bikes football rock guitar and then
you never ride a regular sized bike
again why
because you are an american now and
obviously
recognizing the diversity of asian
americans is about much more than simply
recognizing those three children have
three different faces
because one of the main dangers of
treating asian americans as a single
entity
is that it obscures the reality of what
is happening for the different subgroups
inside it for example
about 10 percent of asian americans live
in poverty which is actually
lower than the overall u.s poverty rate
but when you disaggregate the data
when you break it down by subgroup you
start to see a much more complicated
situation with
mongolian and burmese americans having a
poverty rate of 25 percent
more than twice the national average and
when it comes to education
while around 75 percent of indian
americans have a bachelor's degree
well above the national average for
bhutanese americans
that figure is just 15 which is well
below it the point is
disaggregating the data can reveal big
disparities that you couldn't see
previously
looking at averages for asian americans
as a whole is like
looking at the average income of the
hemsworth brothers it's very misleading
when we all know
some hems are worth a lot more than
other hems are worth
and look using the term asian americans
to represent a political coalition made
sense and still
does to some extent but a coalition
is not a monolith and to start to
understand some of the present day
differences here it really helps to
understand the differences in when
and how people came to this country and
you can break down those experiences
into a few broad categories starting
with those who arrived earlier in the
19th century and the first half of the
20th
asian immigration in that time was
essentially a cycle of economic
exploitation
followed by a violent and restrictive
backlash this began
with chinese immigrants who were
recruited to work on the railroads in
the 1860s
they faced virulent racism from the
beginning both from their bosses who saw
their lives as disposable and from
whites many of whom saw them as
unfair competition for jobs at the time
this senator from california
described chinese immigrants as
automatic engines of flesh and blood
making them sound like some kind of
railroad lane terminators
and demanded that the federal government
secure the american anglo-saxon
civilization
without contamination or adulteration
and in 1882
with the chinese exclusion act he got
his wish
the chinese exclusion law is one of the
first really comprehensively restrictive
laws
and it's also the first and only time in
the entire history of the united states
that a group is singled out by name
chinese by name as being undesirable
so this is truly a remarkable moment yup
the poster said
hip hara to the chinese exclusion act
and if you look at the whole thing it
says in the middle
hip hurrah the white man is on top which
is a bit redundant
if you've said hip hurrah twice you
really don't need to say the white man
is on top
it's like saying blue lives matter or
welcome to carrie bradshaw's bedroom
the white man on top part is very much
implied
and america committed to that exclusion
policy
here is something you might not know
there were actually six chinese men
who survived the sinking of the titanic
but upon reaching u.s shores
were not permitted to enter the united
states to recover instead
they were forced onto another boat and
sent away the very next day
which isn't just racist it's insensitive
did it really have to be
another boat they had just been on the
best boat
and it sucked could you not put
them on a zeppelin
or something at the very least let's try
and mix up the doomed turn of the
century transportation methods here
and the experience of chinese immigrants
unfortunately
set the template for the different
groups that followed because waves of
japanese
korean south asian and filipino
immigrants later came over as
agricultural workers
with those in charge often pitting the
groups against each other with unequal
wages and treatment
each group that came face the common
experience of racial hostility
violence and laws denying them the
possibility of becoming citizens or
owning land
here is a poster targeting chinese
people here is a sign
targeting japanese people and here is
one targeting filipinos
it's just like the statue of liberty
says give me your tired your poor
your huddled masses but not over there
not there either definitely not in maine
you know what
you guys just figured out don't worry
the signs will make it really obvious
and no matter how long asian americans
or their families had been in this
country they were
as now treated as perpetual foreigners
whose loyalties were in question
with the most famous example of this
being the world war ii
internment camps where a hundred and
twenty thousand japanese americans
who've been rounded up on mass were
imprisoned and to add insult to injury
when they were finally allowed to leave
the us government had the gall
to try and give it a positive spin if
you don't have money enough to get to
your new location
the government through wra will make a
grant of enough money to get you there
and a little extra until the paychecks
start coming in
this money does not have to be repaid
it's a helping hand from uncle sam
it's a big moment when you start to pack
for your trip outside
it's an even bigger moment when you walk
through the gate
for the last time and present your past
to the guard
for the last time and take a look at the
barbed wire fence for the last time
and as you look at that barbed wire you
can think you america
for the last time go ahead we're cool
with it you can even say it out loud if
you want to we'll pretend we didn't hear
you and then we'll be even in fact you
know what let's shake on that you can
say you america
one time and then we'll be cool
but around the middle of the last
century attitudes began to shift as the
us
locked in a cold war came to see
exclusion laws and racial quotas as bad
for its global image
so laws like the chinese exclusion act
went away to eventually be replaced
by the 1965 immigration act and this
is the next broad category of asian
american immigrants
those who came post 1965 as a result of
that act
because in contrast to the previous
migrants who were generally relegated to
low-wage manual labor a key thing that
this law did
was prioritize educated and highly
skilled workers like doctors and
engineers and it also tried to address
specific labor needs like when a nursing
shortage resulted in overseas ads like
these
labor recruiters and travel agencies
started targeting filipino nurses with
ads that promised them bright futures in
america
one particular ad featured a basket
that was decorated with the philippine
flag
it's addressing the filipino nurse
saying dear nurse
if you're not happy where you are right
now
contact us and we can't promise you
happiness but we can help you
chase it all over the place i've got to
say that is a refreshingly honest slogan
you might not catch happiness but you
can chase it and it did seem to work as
nurses are one of this country's top
imports from the philippines followed
closely by of course jollibee
the world's greatest fast food mascot
because believe me
unlike american labor recruiters in the
60s jolly b
can promise you happiness and deliver it
to you in videos like this
[Music]
yes please i don't know what i love more
there jolly bee tastefully shaking that
stinger like it's a bottle of his
signature banana ketchup or
the koi flutter of those naughty
humanoid eyes
jollibee can get it
so very broadly asian americans before
1965 were largely exploited for their
labor and legally discriminated against
while
after 1965 there were many more who came
as skilled workers
and who faced fewer formal legal
barriers and then
there's the final group here that has
less to do with america's labor needs
and more to do with its geopolitical
interests those who arrived
as refugees because between 1975 and
2010 we took in over a million refugees
from vietnam
laos and cambodia which wasn't so much
generous
as it was a direct result of people
seeking refuge from wars that america
waged in the region basically
we bombed the out of their
countries to thwart the spread of
communism
sometimes in secret wars to fulfill
henry kissinger's napalm kink
and then once we took those refugees in
we didn't really do much to set them up
for success
when it comes to refugees we hold a lot
of trauma a lot of ptsd
a lot of mental illness from the war and
the genocide we have in the u.s
with respect to our refugee policy this
doctrine of work
first or work immediately it doesn't
matter if you just came from a war zone
and haven't healed from the mental and
physical traumas of war we want you to
get a low wage
job immediately and that is really the
full spectrum of the american experience
isn't it to go from the u.s not giving a
about your life abroad to not
giving a about your life here
good luck and by the way if you think
you hear bombs again try not to freak
out it's either a holiday half the
country kind of hates or some couple
telling their friends what gender their
baby is
welcome to america the point is
different groups of asian americans have
had vastly divergent migration
experiences
and when you understand them more the
variation you see in everything from
income to education to health outcomes
begins to make sense and yet groups that
have in some ways
so little in common often have been
unified unfortunately
through the common experience of bigotry
as was the case in the early 1980s when
america's fear of an economically
ascendant japan led to a racist
fervor at home pretty soon the finger of
blame
ended up on japan
[Music]
all of this hatred you could feel it it
was palpable
detroiters were invited for 50 cents a
smash to take out their anger on
japanese cars
wow that's stupid i honestly can't think
of a single good reason to
beat up a car except maybe if lightning
mcqueen owes you money and to be honest
even then if you really want to hurt him
you don't beat him with a sledgehammer
you
light mater on fire and you make him
watch that's what you do
everybody knows that where is my
money mcqueen
but tragically and unsurprisingly that
type of resentment and blame turn to
violence and eventually culminated in
the murder of vincent chin
a chinese-american man who was beaten to
death by two white men who blamed him
for what japan
was doing to the u.s auto industry
chin's killers were arrested and
convicted but
the judge sentenced them to exactly no
prison time
instead giving each of them three years
probation and less than four thousand
dollars in fines and he insisted at the
time
he'd made the right decision judge
charles kaufman says justice was done
he would not talk to cbs news but he did
tell a detroit newspaper that the two
defendants were long-time hard-working
members of the community
adding these men are not going to go out
and harm somebody else i just didn't
think that putting them in prison would
do any good for them
or for society oh it gets worse that
judge also said
these weren't the kind of men you send
to jail
and it's hard to tell what criteria that
judge used to decide what kind of men
these two murderers were was it the
colour of the skin on their faces the
color of the skin on their hands or just
judicial instinct a gut feeling that
these two men were in fact
white that's the thing about the
criminal justice system at the end of
the day it's more race art
than race science but the enduring
legacy of the vincent chin case was that
it managed to bring asian americans of
all ethnicities together
to call for justice and out of that
sprang a new chapter of asian american
activism
and political identity and that is just
the most famous example
of a rich history of asian american
activism which has often worked across
racial lines
from the student strike that we
mentioned earlier to filipino labor
leaders working with cesar chavez to
organize a grape boycott to yuri
kochiyama's friendship with malcolm x
and her advocacy for marginalized people
of all backgrounds
and yet a prevailing narrative most
people hear regarding asian americans
is one of conflicts between them and
other communities of color
like during the 1992 la uprising and
look
it's not that those tensions aren't very
real but it's not the whole picture
either
and it's also a narrative that fits into
a much larger pattern
in which white america has actively
pitted asian americans
against other communities and that
brings us
to the second half of this sentence and
the model minority myth
the idea of the model minority emerged
over half a century ago in part
because some asian americans were
strategically typecasting themselves in
a bid
to enhance their demands for racial
equality and they did so by
promoting their communities as
upstanding and hard-working
and as immigration law began selecting
for skilled
and educated asian immigrants the
credentials of those new arrivals
seem to conform to the stereotype which
then took on a life of its own
especially in the civil rights era as
whites unnerved by black americans
radical challenges to the system
held up japanese and chinese americans
and their success
as evidence that they claimed disproved
systemic racism
very basically america prioritized
wealthy more educated asian immigrants
then
turned to black people who'd been
subjugated for centuries and said see
they're educated and successful why
aren't you
and using asian american success to
downplay american racism
is a trend that very much continues to
this day
if america were such a hate-filled
discriminatory racist society
filled with animus against asian
americans
how do you explain the remarkable
success of asian americans in our
country their mindset
is to just work really hard it's not to
protest things
and not to shut things down it's just oh
yeah they're in the library the asians
the whole reason why they kick ass is
because they don't spend any time on
petty
asians are concerned about hate crimes
but they're very upwardly mobile very
success oriented
very business oriented they're model
citizens in many cases in my view
probably the most admirable ethnic group
we have wow
congratulations asian americans dick
morris thinks you're the most admirable
ethnic group we have
that's so sweet of him to say if you
want to write dick a thank you note just
address the envelope to shove this right
up dick morris's ass
new york new york whatever zip code dick
morris's
is in a central premise of the modern
minority myth is that the key to
overcoming american racism
is simply strong values and hard work
with the implication being
that groups that haven't succeeded
simply haven't tried hard enough
and putting aside how offensive that is
the truth is whether or not you're
successful
living a life defined by a racist
fantasy just
isn't good for you striving to maintain
the idea of a model minority
has really severed my self-esteem
it really makes me feel that i'm nothing
more than someone who could
get good grades someone who was supposed
to be perfect and be mom about
everything
right trying to be perfect your whole
life is going to be
too much to bear that is why i made a
promise when i started this show that
i'd always get one fact in every story
completely wrong
is that responsible absolutely not but
it is what keeps me looking young
and the model minority myth is
especially calling for some members of
groups like those whose families came as
refugees
whose lived experience doesn't remotely
match the stereotype
the truth is that kind of pressure can
do
real damage suicide is the leading cause
of death for asian americans between the
ages of 15
and 24 and yet apparently only eight
percent of asian americans
sought help for their mental health
which is less than half
the rate of the general population and
that is not just a result of cultural
stigmas around mental health
it's also what happens when you're
consistently told
to quietly and happily accept
discrimination because your version
is the nice racism but there is no nice
racism there is no silver lining to it
and there is no
working your way out of it you are still
perpetually treated as a foreigner
still asked where you're really from and
asian americans
always seem to be just one geopolitical
crisis away
from becoming the target of violence yet
again whether it's those
internment camps for japanese americans
or the spate of attacks
on south asians after 9 11 or all of the
recent racial violence during the
pandemic
so the model minority myth is both a
tool of white supremacy
and a trap and as with so many things in
this story with a community
this diverse there are going to be
different perspectives on how to handle
it
andrew yang has annoyed some by leaning
into it with
self-deprecating jokes and his
math hat
and he also angered many when he
responded to the trump administration's
china virus rhetoric by writing an op-ed
in which he claimed
we asian americans need to embrace and
show our americanness in ways we never
have before
by among other things wearing red white
and blue
that argument prompted a backlash with
eddie wong tweeting
out of here with this america drag
you bumbling pineapple bun
and i do get that because it's pretty
insulting to suggest
two centuries of racism could be
defeated by serving uncle sam
realness so all of that is
very simplistically too broadly and
probably too quickly
and a bridged version of how we all got
to where we are right now
so where do we go from here well what is
clear is we have to find a way
to have smarter more nuanced
conversations about the reality of the
asian american experience and we cannot
do that
with our access to high quality
disaggregated data
that can help better fit public policy
to the actual needs of individual
communities
but that is not all because asian
americans have been warning for decades
about all of this just watch a man tell
a reporter
five years before i was even born what
i've been trying to tell you tonight
during yet another of those old model
minority profiles
but i suggested that compared to the
black and the chicano the japanese
american has it made he can get a job
a place to live it's a situation where i
think the question is not material
making in terms of economics but a
question basically of human dignity
you know what i mean in terms of human
dignity like for example we've been set
in a certain category and many people
argue
man you got a good stereotype you got a
stereotype to get you apartments where
you don't have to play a keen cleaning
deposit because
you're so goddamn clean that's our
stereotype but it's an infringement it's
a violation of our human
dignity because they don't view us as
individuals as human beings
we fit into a certain category we fit
into a certain box that's how they view
us
he's right it's a category it's a box
but the thing is
you don't learn anything from it unless
you bother to look inside
because obviously no group community or
indeed individual
is just one thing and when you reduce
the asian american experience to that of
a model minority
you are omitting a history that includes
exploitation and exclusion
but also includes activism some
infighting challenges with issues like
immigration education and access to
social services that continue to this
day
and an array of interests and
achievements that go
far beyond these two guys to be as vast
and diverse
as america itself by the way can you see
who's in there
i told you kareem i told you i got your
back
i see you kareem and look i know this
story has barely skimmed the surface of
this subject but i hope
that it's at least introduced some of
you to a bit of the history involved
here
as well as what i think we can all agree
is the world's most
bee that's our show thank you
so much for watching we'll see you next
week
good night
you